[Music]
we are
Brendan Fraser okay you've been in so
many iconic movies I would love for you
to share some fun facts about them that
we've never heard before are you ready
to play the game yes
[Applause]
something we didn't know Encino Man yes
uh Elizabeth or Encino Man also known as
was played in the director's reel to get
a green light to make the movie by none
other than Ben Stiller what
that's the kind of stuff I'm talking
about that's so fun okay
School Ties I think that it was a film
that um came out at an important time in
uh American history it was released when
there were people taking to the streets
in Outrage for a clear good reason
in Los Angeles
because of the Discord that that that
comes from how we don't get along with
one another and and and and this film
was
an example of what happens when we have
less understanding and more open
communication
um it's a film that's it it it it it
calls out Prejudice in the form of
anti-Semitism however
um
it has
um
a lot of work it did a lot of work for
the time that it came out
because of it being set in the 50s and
we had a sense of you know remove from
the 1990s to the 1950s and we could ask
ourselves well that was then this is not
now but the truth is there is there are
social issues that are happening now and
it was it gave us
um an example of how we need to learn to
get along with one another
it's as important now as it was then and
thank you for making it it's such a
Beloved movie it is so important
all right pivot and genre we're gonna go
to air
heads
[Applause]
facts um I I don't play the guitar I
don't think Adam played the drums I
think Steve could get by on base pretty
well so when I told this to Michael
Layman I'm not a musician because that's
fine none of those guys are anyway
so he gave me the job
to make lots of Records he's on tour
right now selling out like 80 000 people
stadiums so
I guess I mean just oh my God but I
loved this time I loved this movie so
much it's so good okay
okay
George
[Applause]
what do you want to know
like how long did it take to get
comfortable in a loincloth
um I never really did to be honest
he was kind of naked was it like body
makeup you know yes I was spray painted
like I was in an auto body shop every
morning a guy with a rebreather on
um and it it look it was broad comedy
great fun to do
um based on a Jay Ward property that was
George of the Jungle in the 70s and the
60s was kind of like The Simpsons of its
time is it delivered subversive humor in
a way that you weren't expecting to get
a message across but doing it in the
guys of comedy and so that set the tone
for
um you know a broad comedy like this to
to um to make sense that a guy that
lives in the jungle and has
um a dog that's actually an elephant
um is is entertainment
don't you think it's funny that when
you're being airbrushed the guy has like
the gas mask on but you're just standing
there yeah you're like
and now there's a person there like like
and that's the coordinator
I know thank you
okay
I mean a franchise of you know
establishing what everyone got hungry
for The Mummy yeah
we had no idea if this film was a horror
film a comedy film a straight ahead
action film a romance a a an epic and
then just decide well all of it let them
decide and
I guess they liked it
I I would say so
[Applause]
we used to have a genre called caper and
a technology ruined the Caper because
now you can just call and be like run
for your life they're coming for you
instead we had to like get to the thing
to save it but you could have action you
could have Adventure you could have
comedy you could have romance and you
could have terror and and horror and it
wasn't in front of a piece of green
cloth exactly I never could succeed I
went to the place if I had to act to a
tennis ball I would fail miserably I'm
really good at it you are I happen to be
really good at it you know why because
in The Mummy Returns
um Dwayne The Rock Johnson was just a
piece of tape on a stick
when I did um Looney Tunes back in
Action there there was thank you there
was a Daffy Duck puppeted by Bruce
lenoyle and it uh helped so much for
your eye lines you don't have that I'm
looking at a piece of tape on a tennis
ball right you can interact with one
another which made perfect sense and um
also I have bragging rights to having
worked at Daffy Duck properly in the
flash by the way
Daffy is a real jerk I'm telling you
well you know I mean bugs on the other
hand he's the Iceman seriously I'm tight
with bugs I raised mine it really is a
good guy people go what's he really
liked no seriously he's a good guy I
raised my kids on Looney Tunes and I
feel very strongly I think everything
you need to know about acting you can
find a lesson for in a Warner Brothers
cartoon particularly by Tex Avery okay
thank you Brendan the whale is in
theaters right now we'll be back
[Music]
foreign
[Music]